أُخرج الحلاج من زنزانته تحت حراسة مشددة،
وجيء به مقيدا بالاغلال إلى ساحة في قلب بغداد لتنفيذ حكم الصلب،
كان الحلاج شامخا جليلا،
وأمامه حشد عظيم اجتمع على ضفاف نهر دجلة،
وكان يردد؛
هَؤَلاءَ عِبَادُكَ،
قَدْ اجْتَمَعُوا لِقَتْلِى تَعَصُّباً لدِينكَ،
وتَقَرُّباً إليْكَ،
فاغْفرْ لَهُمْ !
فإنكَ لَوْ كَشَفْتَ لَهُمْ مَا كَشَفْتَ لِى،
لما فَعَلُوا ما فَعلُوا،
ولَوْ سَتَرْتَ عَنِّى مَا سَترْتَ عَنْهُمْ،
لما لَقِيتُ مَا لَقِيتُ،
فَلَكَ الحمدُ فِيما تَفْعَلُ
ولَكَ الحمدُ فيِما تُرِيدُ.
شدّ صاحب الشرطة الحلاج إلى آلة الصلب بعد أن لطمه لطمة هشمت أنفه،
وأمر الجلاّد بأن يضربه ألف سوط،
كان الحلاج صامدا لا يتأوه ولا يستعفي،
فقط كان يردد أحدٌ أحد.
ثم تقدم الجلاد بسيفه وقطع يده اليمني،
ثم يده اليسرى،
ولما اصفرّ وجهه لكثرة ما نزف من دمه،
مرر ذراعه النازفة على وجهه وخضّبه بالدم وقال مبتسما؛
"ركعتان في العشق لا يصح وضوؤهما إلاّ بالدم"،
ثمّ ردّد؛
أقتلوني يا ثُقاتي
إِنَّ في قَتلي حَياتي
وَمَماتي في حَياتي
وَحَياتي في مَماتي
أَنا عِندي مَحوُ ذاتي
مَن أَجَلَّ المَكرُماتِ
وَبَقائي في صِفاتي
مِن قَبيحِ السَيِّئاتِ
سَئِمَتْ روحي حَياتي
في الرُسومِ البالِياتِ
فَاِقتُلوني وَاِحرِقوني
بِعِظامي الفانِياتِ
ثُمَّ مُرّوا بِرُفاتي
في القُبورِ الدارِساتِ
تَجِدوا سِرَّ حَبيبي
في طَوايا الباقِياتِ.
استمعوا إلى هذه الأبيات بصوت الفنان أحمد حويلي؛
أقتلوني يا ثُقاتي
إِنَّ في قَتلي حَياتي
وَمَماتي في حَياتي
وَحَياتي في مَماتي
أَنا عِندي مَحوُ ذاتي
مَن أَجَلَّ المَكرُماتِ
وَبَقائي في صِفاتي
مِن قَبيحِ السَيِّئاتِ
سَئِمَتْ نفسي
سَئِمَتْ نفسي حَياتي
في الرُسومِ البالِياتِ
فَاِقتُلوني
وَاِحرِقوني
بِعِظامي الفانِياتِ
ثُمَّ مُرّوا
ثُمَّ مُرّوا بِرُفاتي
في القُبورِ الدارِساتِ
تَجِدوا
َجِدوا سِرَّ حَبيبي
حَبيبي
في طَوايا الباقِياتِ.
أرجوكم أقتلوني
أقتلوني وَاِحرِقوني بِعِظامي الفانِياتِ
هذه الكلمات للحلاج ومشهد جلده وقطع يديه،
أثارت غضب الناس في ساحة الصلب،
فأسرع الجنود إلى بعض الفقهاء الحاضرين،
وأمروهم بأن يلعنوا الحلاج وينالوا منه أمام العامة.
ومضى اليوم وغربت الشمس،
وبات الحلاج مصلوبا مقطوع اليدين ودمائه تنزف،
ورابط اهل بغداد طوال الليل في ساحة الصلب.
وفي صباح اليوم الثاني قُطعت رجله اليمنى ثمّ اليسرى.
يقول الخطيب البغدادي:
«سمعت فارسًا يقول:
قُطعت أعضاء الحلَّاج، عضوًا عضوًا
وما تغير لونه، وما فتر لسانه عن ذكر الله.»
كان أعوان الوزير حامد يصيحون في الناس؛
أقتلوا الحلاج الزنديق وفي أعناقنا دمه،
ويجيؤون بشيوخ الصوفية والفقهاء لرجم جسد الحلاج الذي ينزف دما،
ومضى اليوم الثاني والليلة الثانية
والحلاج لازال حيا معلّقا على صليبه.
أسرع الحاجب نصرالقشوري ليخبر الخليفة بخطورة الوضع في بغداد،
ونصحه بأن يصدر أمرا بالعفو على جسد الحلاج الممزق
قبل أن تقوم ثورة على خلافته.
ولكن الوزير حامد رفض ذلك قائلا للخليفة؛
ان العفو عن الحلاج في هذه اللحظة سيشعل بغداد
أكثر مما يشعله قتله والتخلص منه نهائيا،
وصاح؛
اقتله يا أمير المؤمنين، وفي عنقي دمه،
اقتله وإن حدثت الثورة التي يتنبأ بها نصر فاقتلني،
اقتله قبل أن تثور العاصفة!
وخضع المقتدر لابن العباس،
وأمر بقطع رأس الحلاج وحرق جسده.
يقول ابن كثير؛
"فلما كان اليوم الثالث، تقدم حامد إلى الخشبة، فتلا أمر الخليفة،
ثم قرأ فتوى الفقهاء، بأن في قتل الحلَّاج صلاحَ أمر المسلمين !
ثم أمر الجلاد بقطع رأسه والإجهاز عليه."
ثم صُبّ على جسده النفط وأُحرق،
وحمل رماده على رأس منارةٍ ونُثر في نهر دجلة،
في السادس والعشرين من ذي القعدة، سنة تسع وثلاثمائة هجري
الموافق ل 26  مارس/اذار سنة 922 ميلادي،
وظلّ رأسه معلّقا يومين على الجسر ببغداد،
ثم طِيف به في خراسان،
ثم أخذته أم الخليفة المقتدر، فحنطته وعطرته،
وأبقته في خزانتها عامًا كاملا.
لم يكتف الوزير حامد والخليفة المقتدر بحرق جسد الحلاّج،
ولكن أمرا كذلك بحرق كتبه وأثاره،
ومنع تداول كل ما يشير إلى ذكراه عند الورّاقين.
لكن كلمة الفصل لم تكن لهما بل كانت للتاريخ،
فقتل الوزير حامد بن العباس بعد سنتين،
سنة 311 هجري أفظع قتلة وقُطعت يداه ورجلاه.
وقتل الخليفة المقتدر سنة 320 هجري على يد قائد الجيش مؤنس الخادم.
وقتل الخليفة القاهر بدروره قائد الجيش مؤنس التركي سنة 321 هجري.
وكل هؤلاء لا يذكرهم التاريخ،
إلا على هامشه عند حديثه عن الحسين بن منصور الحلاج،
الذي قطعت أفكاره قرونا من الزمن وامتدت ذكراه لأكثر من ألف عام،
ليعيد لها المستشرق الفرنسي لوي ماسينيون وهجها وبريقها
من خلال كتابه آلام الحلاج.
ادعوكم إلى الإطلاع على هذا الكتاب الهام للوي ماسينيون،
و احيطكم علما ان الجزء الأوّل قد ترجمه المترجم حسين الحلاج،
نعم يحمل نفس اسم الشهيد الحسين بن منصور الحلاج،
وصدر عن دار نينوى بدمشق.
كما أنصحكم بالإطلاع على كتاب الكاتب العراقي على بدر،
"ماسينيون في بغداد من الإهتداء الصوفي إلى الهداية الكولونيالية"،
وكذلك كتاب شخصيات قلقة في الإسلام للمفكر عبد الرحمان بدوي،
وكذلك كتاب الحلاج شهيد التصوف الإسلامي لصاحبه طه عبد الباقي سرور.
اشكركم جزيل الشكرعلى المتابعة،
ولا تنسوا الإشتراك بقناة انا أفكر إذن أنا موجود،
وتفعيل الجرس ليصلكم كل جديد،
دمتم بخير وإلى لقاء قريب...